other news the White House says planning
is underway for another meeting between
President Trump and Russian President
Vladimir Putin this fall in Washington
this comes as President Obama's
Secretary of State John Kerry is
denouncing this week's Helsinki summit
as indefensible John Kerry spoke with
Face the Nation moderator and CBS News
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan about his upcoming book
every day is extra Margaret asked him
about Monday's Trump Putin news
conference
I found it shocking I found it to be one
of the most disgraceful remarkable
moments of cow towing to a foreign
leader by an American president that
anyone has ever witnessed and it wasn't
just that it was a kind of surrender
it's that it is dangerous the president
stood there and did not defend our
country he stood there and did not
defend the truth he did not defend the
facts and the danger here's why it's
dangerous because it sends a message to
President Putin and to the rest of the
world that the president United States
the leader of the free world really
doesn't have a handle on what he's doing
and that he doesn't you know know either
what the facts are or he won't accept
the facts so you don't buy his walk back
I don't buy his walk back one second and
by the way mark Brennan is with us from
Washington good morning Margot good
morning
so what do we know about this second
summit that's been announced from the
White House well it seems the meeting
was the message the White House US is
the only agreement that was made was to
hold another meeting this time in
Washington there was no breakthrough
deal in Helsinki to end the war in Syria
were to counter Iran's influence there
both things
ambassador Bolton said would be topics
President Trump did not hammer out the
nuclear arms control agreement that he
said he wanted but we know those will be
topics at this second meeting in the
fall basically the message seems to be
here that in case there was any doubt
President Trump is ending the Obama era
policy of isolating and punishing Russia
for violating international law and
there also doesn't seem to be any update
on the
using relationship with Russia as a
counterweight against China which the
president had talked about before but
then didn't come out afterwards so
within the administration was this the
agreed-upon plan or was this an
improvisation by the president do we
think this idea of a second summit well
there had been the idea of follow-on
talks to have this nuclear arms control
agreement actually you know result in a
path to extend the so-called New START
deal but at the presidential level it
was a bit of a surprise President Trump
told his team that in Helsinki
he held a really firm line with Vladimir
Putin on the war in Syria and that you
know he made some clear insistence here
that the US isn't going to withdraw US
troops until Iranian backed forces do
this is what he is telling his team he
said but as we know no one except the
people in the room really know and those
are only the two men themselves the two
leaders what was agreed upon and what
was perhaps suggested so what the White
House says in an agreement doesn't
necessarily line up with what the
Russians say are various concepts ideas
and proposals that were agreed upon well
Margaret talking about surprises the top
intelligence official was clearly
surprised we saw that in real time does
anybody in the White House say you know
what maybe we should have given Dan a
heads up about that is there any
reflection on that move that the
Director of National Intelligence I mean
he looked he looked gobsmacked yeah on
television that was awful position for
him to be in you know he runs 17
different intelligence agencies he's not
part of planning a state visit but he's
at this point this far after the summit
you would have thought he received a
debrief on what happened in that meeting
with Vladimir Putin considering the
number of issues that touch his
portfolio the war in Syria North Korea
etc so it was surprising we should note
we should note that Russia says they
were surprised by that invitation and
they are considering the invitation all
right thank you very much Margaret